und jetzt das heute journal mit kai soll
berichte und marietta slomka
guten abend das thema gas umlage habe
ihm die letzten 48 stunden den tag
versaut hatte robert habeck am
donnerstag gesagt nun diese 48 stunden
werde noch länger dauern das problem
beschäftigt ihn weiterhin und ist
weiterhin unerfreulich für den minister
über den jetzt sogar ampel kollegen wie
der spd chef öffentlich sticheln in der
politik zählten nicht schöne worte
sondern substanz und jetzt müsste man
die handwerklichen fehler ausräumen im
fußball nennt man das wohl
ellenbogencheck hinzu kommt die
forderung dass der wirtschaftsminister
auch etwas gegen die hohen strompreise
tun müsse zu erleben gleich ein
interview mit robert habeck vorweg ein
bericht von patricia wiedemeier über die
gaskrise und andere energiefragen
es sind derzeit keine leichten zeiten
für den wirtschaftsminister der tour
durchs land besucht wasserstoff
zukunftsprojekte in gelsenkirchen obwohl
die probleme der gegenwart gar nicht
gelöst sind die preise für strom und gas
explodieren und die regierung sie agiert
zerstritten und hilflos beispiel eins
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
geht nur schleppend voran vor allem bei
der windenergie an land es war zwar
schon die vorgängerregierung die die
windkraft nicht weiter ausbaute seit dem
jahre 2000 17 gegen der bau neuer
anlagen deutlich zurück aber auch die
ampel tue zu wenig kritisiert der
verband in der windenergie hält derzeit
weit weiter die flaute an wir haben
weder bei den genehmigungen noch im zug
auch derzeit ein fortschritt die
flächenausweisung werden erst 2032
abgeschlossen sein das ist viel zu spät
und lässt eine lücke von knapp zehn
jahren genau diese erfahrungen hat auch
heinz thier gemacht im münsterland im
kreis coesfeld arbeitet er als berater
für die bauern und bürger vor ort
betreut seit zehn jahren die errichtung
von windkraftanlagen er fordert deutlich
schnellere genehmigungsverfahren
keine so komplizierten bauanträge wie
bisher und beim artenschutz manchmal
scheitert es an den einfachen dingen
beim artenschutz ist es so dass wir
einen einjährigen untersuchungszeitraum
haben ornithologen müsste also ein jahr
lang in feld und flur die vogelwelt
beobachten und wir haben jetzt schon die
situation dass die ornithologen für
nächstes jahr für 2023 schon vollständig
ausgebucht sind
genehmigungsverfahren in sechs monaten
statt in sechs jahren wie der kanzler
ist mal versprochen hatte völlig
unrealistisch wir haben alleine wenn die
flächen verfügbar sind wie gesagt ein
jahr artenschutz wir haben ein jahr im
halt bauantragsverfahren
und dann hat der hersteller noch
anderthalb jahre lieferzeit und insofern
selbst wenn wir heute im bauantrag
stellen führen wenn die anlagen sie
frühestens in drei jahren drehen bei der
solarenergie sieht es etwas besser aus
hier geht es voran die nachfrage ist
seit beginn des ukraine krieges enorm
gestiegen aber auch hier müsse die
regierung mehr liefern ein booster für
die erneuerbaren fordert der nabu wir
wünschen uns zum beispiel ein herbst
paket der bundesregierung in dem die
solardach pflicht kommt die wurde schon
im koalitionsvertrag angekündigt ist
aber noch nicht in sichtweite hier ist
das bundeswirtschaftsministerium in der
pflicht und auch das
bundesbauministerium konkrete pläne
vorzulegen problem nummer zwei hastig
hat robert habeck eine gasanlage
zusammengeschustert als rettung für die
gas ein käufer ab oktober soll jeder
kunde zahlen doch die umlage ist nicht
auf notleidende energiekonzerne
beschränkt spd und fdp warnen
nachbesserungen ansprechen von
handwerklichen fehlern habe verspricht
änderungen
die gasanlage sollte nachgesteuert
werden weil hier tatsächlich im moment
zu sehr auch gewinne gemacht werden von
unternehmen die gar nicht von der
insolvenz bedroht werden das muss man
dringend nachsteuern aber gleichzeitig
auch auf dem weg bringen eine art über
gewinn steuer damit die unternehmen
nicht zusätzliche profite machen das
geld sollte man zurückgeben an
zielgerichtet an betroffene haushalte
und unternehmen
eine über gewinn steuer die die grünen
schon lange fordern die die fdp und ihr
finanzminister aber ebenso lange schon
ablehnen problem nummer drei die
laufzeit der atommeiler sollen die drei
verbliebenen kraftwerke am netz bleiben
oder wie geplant abgeschaltet werden die
opposition fordert immer wieder ein
weiterbetrieb auch der csu-chef heute in
berlin direkt sommerinterview kein
mensch versteht warum seit monaten die
grünen dieses thema blockieren es geht
nicht um das 10 neu gebaut werden wir
brauchen jetzt ersatz energie wir haben
die nicht die kernenergie kann einen
wichtigen beitrag leisten für strom für
strompreissenkung für die frage ob wir
verstromung aus gas machen müssen zwei
wochen wird das verschlag mehr
wasserkraft mehr bioenergie und eben
auch weiter kernkraft fordert würde doch
der weiterbetrieb der atommeiler er
bleibt umstritten ich halte es nicht für
richtig die atomlaufzeiten jetzt zu
verlängern ist birgt enorme kosten
risiken und vor allem dauert es zeit wir
haben kurzfristig viel mehr
möglichkeiten bei den erneuerbaren
energien sowohl bei der windenergie die
zertifizierung bei der solarenergie
aussetzen die biomasse hat mehr
kapazitäten das kann man kurzfristig
kurzfristiger zeit aufheben auch in
bayern es sind viele baustellen viele
probleme für den einstigen sunnyboy der
ampel
darüber wollen wir mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister reden guten
abend der hwk
slomka ihr ampel partner spd-chef
klingbeil hat gerade gesagt also immer
nur schöne worte das reicht jetzt nicht
jetzt müssen konkrete lösungen her
können sie uns denn mehr oder weniger
schönen worten erklären ob sie schon
eine lösung haben für dieses gas umlagen
problem
das war mir zeit wo alle sehr unter
druck stehen das kann man verstehen
deswegen muss man jetzt hart an dem
problem arbeiten und das tun wir auch
bei der gasanlage beziehungsweise bei
dem teil der gasanlage der unschön ist
nämlich das unternehmen sie ausnutzen
als trittbrettfahrer quasi um ebenfalls
abrechnungen zu stellen unternehmen dies
gar nicht nötig hätten wir werden dieses
problem lösen na ja sie haben auch
gesagt die verdienen ein schweinegeld
aber das ist ja jetzt ein ökonomisches
kriterium schweine geld zu verdienen und
mit moralischen appellen kann man ja
wenn man so eine umlage auf macht auch
nicht kommen die unternehmensführung
sind geradezu verpflichtet dann auch so
was sich wenn sowas einzutragen wie
könnte es dann aussehen also sie
begrenzen die zugangsberechtigten oder
gehen sie ganz runter von dieser umlage
und helfen lieber direkt dem unternehmen
dem so schlecht geht
nein das erste ist die lösung wir müssen
sehen dass die unternehmen die
eigentlich keinen zugang zu dieser
umlage brauchen ihn auch nicht bekommen
und wie gesagt das ist ein problem wir
arbeiten an einer lösung die umlage
selbst das habe ich ja nie verheimlicht
ist ein unangenehmer schritt eine
unangenehme entscheidung aber eine
notwendige entscheidung weil die
alternative gewesen wäre dass die
gasunternehmen die am markt
gescheitert sind weil sie ihr
geschäftsmodell auf billigen muss ich
schon gas aufgebaut haben jetzt das
nicht mehr gekommen neues teures gas
nachkaufen müssen diese preise irgendwie
kompensieren müssen und der staat ist
reingegangen wir haben ja zwei
unternehmen gazprom germania und juniper
mit milliardenbeträgen gestützt ist
reingegangen aber eine dauerhafte
finanzierung durch den staat ist eben
noch kein geschäftsmodell und deswegen
mussten wir diese umlage wählen oder
eben die kunden dieser unternehmen
alleine mit den unternehmen lassen diese
umlage ist also ein solidaritäts
mechanismus das ist wohl so entschieden
worden na ja man hätte es ja auch sagen
können man beteiligt sich daran man
verstaatlicht die oder man kauft sich da
ein wir hatten bei der lufthansa sohn
modell wir hatten bei der großen
finanzkrise bankenrettungen hättest dann
wirklich diese umlage gebraucht die nun
auch alle gaskunden bezahlen
wir sind ja in den unternehmen drin
jedenfalls in zwei sehr großen
unternehmen drin und das ist schon eine
große menge des deutschen gasmarktes
staatlich gestützt ist aber auch
staatlich gestützte unternehmen brauchen
ja am ende eine möglichkeit ihre kosten
umzulegen und das war der lufthansa auch
so die haben dann ja auch weiter
gewirtschaftet und der staat hat nicht
die flugpreise die ticketpreise
übernommen also insofern wir haben sind
staatlich stark reingegangen aber das
geschäftsmodell muss natürlich in
irgendeiner form dann tragen und die
situation um es noch einmal deutlich zu
machen ist nicht in erster linie die
unternehmen zu stützen die unternehmen
sind nur dass wir die situationen oder
die herausforderung ist die versorgung
der deutschen bevölkerung und der
unternehmen mit gas zu gewährleisten und
eben die stand in gefahr immerhin die
gasspeicher haben sie jetzt doch gesagt
die sind jetzt einigermaßen gefüllt als
es um das setzen wir im winter nicht im
kalten nur die frage ist welche preise
man dann zahlen muss richtig
ja ich würde es ein bisschen anders
einordnen wir arbeiten unter extremen
anspannung und in einer sehr brenzlichen
situation und man sieht natürlich vor
allem immer wieder die probleme man muss
aber auch sehen was schon erreicht wurde
und da ist es tatsächlich eine gute
nachricht dass die speicher die jetzt
heute da stand bei 82 prozent liegen 85
prozent war das ziel ende september
anfang oktober also wir haben fast einen
monat früher das ziel erreicht das wir
eigentlich erreichen wollten das heißt
das war sehr erfolgreich wenn wir die
gesetze klug gemacht haben weil wir auch
genug geld bereit gestellt haben diese
speicher zu füllen und die nachricht die
sich damit verbindet ist dass das gas
nicht in den speichern bleiben soll über
den ganzen winter über das soll ja als
reserve wieder aus gespeichert werden um
dann in der kalten jahreszeit die
versorgungssituation in deutschland zu
stabilisieren
wie stabil sie sein wird das kann keiner
jetzt hat vorher sagen wir haben die
speicher nur so voll so schnell so voll
bekommen weil die verbräuche von gas im
sommer runter gegangen sind und deswegen
ist der up und nach wie vor richtig wir
müssen die gasverbraucher runterbringen
in deutschland und wenn man hohen preis
gezahlt hat nun haben wir nicht nur hohe
gaspreise durch die decke gehen sondern
auch strompreise das liegt gewissermaßen
auch in der natur der sache weil beides
miteinander gekoppelt ist das sind sehr
komplizierten mechanismus können wir
jetzt noch mal zehn minuten theoretisch
darüber reden aber sagen sie mir doch
sie sagen man muss das reformierung
christian lindner sagt das ist so eine
art profit schleuder da am strommarkt
der österreichische kanzler sagt wir
müssen den europäischen strommarkt
reformieren wird er konkret was
passieren kann man das einfach so
entkoppeln
man kann es nicht einfach so mit
fingerschnipsen marktes ein
kompliziertes gebilde aber ja
wir arbeiten auch da an einer lösung
dass die günstigen preise die eher die
erneuerbaren energien noch immer liefern
auch weitergegeben werden an die kunden
und auch die preise die kohlekraftwerke
oder solange wir sie noch haben
atomkraftwerke erzielen sie sind ja
günstiger als die gaskraftwerke die
müssen weitergegeben werden der deutsche
strommarkt funktioniert so dass immer
die günstigsten anbieter zuerst energie
liefern und das höchste gebot dann gilt
das hat einen großen effekt für
innovation und günstige anbieter die er
dann das größte geschäft machen drängen
in den markt deswegen ist der strommarkt
eigentlich sehr gut aufgestellt aber
wenn die nachfrage so groß ist das quasi
alle kapazitäten rein gehen dann hat man
immer die hochleistung das problem dass
wir im moment haben ist das versagen der
französischen atomkraft alle
gaskraftwerke selbst die die die
höchsten preise generieren laufen im
grunde um den strom nach frankreich zu
liefern das ist in deutschland so in
belgien den niederlanden spanien überall
ist das so und das ist unser problem im
moment das heißt da funktioniert der
markt nicht richtig und wir werden das
korrigieren nachdem sie es schon zwei
mal selbst freiwillig das wort atomkraft
sozusagen in den mund nahmen sie wissen
diese forderung dass die atomkraftwerke
doch noch länger laufen liegt auf dem
tisch die grünen wollen das nicht das
wissen wir auch aber sie prüfen ja ob
man streckt wie lang wird dann diese
prüfung noch andauern
die letzte prüfung ktv davor gemacht
haben hat zwei monate gedauert die
dauert jetzt seit drei oder vier wochen
ist sie im gang das heißt wir arbeiten
alle arbeiten mit hochdruck daran die
ergebnisse schnell zu bekommen aber sie
müssen dann eben auch belastbar sein und
das ist eine komplexe operation weil man
eben den ausländischen strommarkt mit
einbeziehen muss sowohl als reserve für
deutschland wie auch als so als absaugen
der strommengen aus deutschland raus und
deswegen müssen markt genau die
bewegungen gerechnet werden aber das
kann ich ihnen versichern alle arbeiten
mit hochdruck daran sagte
bundeswirtschaftsminister
danke für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen
das interview habe vor gut einer stunde
geführt mit den folgen der hohen gas-
und strompreise für haushalte und
unternehmen
gesetze nachricht weiter kann sollte mit
möglichen politischen antworten darauf
die spd fraktion will die energiekrise
mit einem breiten maßnahmepaket abfedern
ein entwurf für die anstehende
fraktionsklausur sie zum beispiel eine
strom- und gaspreis bremse für den
grundbedarf vor ebenso wie
direktzahlungen an besonders bedürftige
gruppen wie geringverdiener studierende
oder rentner außerdem wird ein
monatliches 49 euro ticket vorgeschlagen
finanziert von bund und ländern und auch
unternehmen die durch die hohen preise
in schieflage geraten können auf
unterstützung hoffen krisengewinner
dagegen sollen eine über gewinn steuer
zahlen
im kampf gegen russland will deutschland
die ukraine notfalls jahre lang
unterstützen auch mit schweren waffen
das hat außenministerin berbalk
bekräftigt die ukraine verteidige auch
unsere freiheit unsere friedensordnung
sagte sie der bild am sonntag dieser
krieg könne noch jahre dauern berbalk
stellte sich auch in sachen krim hinter
kiew die halbinsel gehöre zur ukraine
der spanische botschafter melnik hat
sachsens ministerpräsidenten kretschmann
von einem ukraine besuch ausgeladen der
cdu politiker sei unerwünscht schrieb er
auf twitter klitschnass so wirklich
absurde rhetorik über das einfrieren des
krieges befeuere russlands aggressionen
am mittwoch hatte kretschmann im zdf
erneut für einen waffenstillstand und
verhandlungen geworden gleichzeitig
verurteilte er den russischen
angriffskrieg
die nato will ihre aktivitäten in der
arktis verstärken
grund sei eine deutlich erhöhte
militärpräsenz russlands in dem gebiet
so öffnung moskau wieder stützpunkte aus
sowjetzeiten sagte stoltenberg der welt
am sonntag auch china interessieren sich
zunehmend für die arktis die von großer
strategischer bedeutung sei unter dem
eis lagern außerdem große mengen an
bodenschätzen deren abbau mit der
zunehmenden eisschmelze leichter wird
gleichzeitig öffnen sich dadurch neue
handelsrouten
pabst franziskus hat die italienische
stadt l'aquila besucht dort ließ er sich
unter anderem die kathedrale zeigen die
bei dem verheerenden erdbeben vor 13
jahren schwer beschädigt worden war
außerdem betete er am grab von cds
blieben dem fünften dem erster papst der
freiwillig zurücktrat das befeuert
gerüchte über einen möglichen eigenen
rücktritt zumal franziskus gestern 20
neue kardinäle ernannt hatte von denen
16 bei einer papstwahl teilnehmen
könnten
pakistan's klimawandel ministerin
spricht von einer katastrophe epischen
ausmaßes das land erlebt die heftigste
regenzeit seit mindestens zwölf jahren
seit monsun beginnen juni kamen schon
mehr als 1000 menschen ums leben
insgesamt sind mehr als 33 millionen
betroffen ganze dörfer wurden bereits
fortgespült ebenso wie unzählige straßen
und felder das land hat um
internationale hilfe gebeten
die hohen gas- und strompreise die
inflation insgesamt natürlich trifft das
die menschen die eh schon wenig haben am
härtesten das aus der nähe zu sehen mit
zu fühlen und zu helfen ist aufgabe des
armuts beauftragten in berlin zu ihm
kommen menschen bei denen es nicht mehr
darum geht ob sie sich dies oder jenes
noch gönnen können was schon hart genug
ist doch er betreut menschen die
eigentlich gar nicht mehr einsparen
können so begegnen wir gleich in der
reportage von christhard läpple zum
beispiel einen mann der um strom zu
sparen beim eier kochen verzichtet
berlin neukölln weiße straße 34 eine
gute adresse für menschen in not für
menschen die wenig oder nichts habe sind
fast 40 jahren ein anlaufpunkt die tee
und wärmestube des diakonischen werks
tätig kommen mehr fast dreimal so viele
wie bisher alte arme arbeitslose
eu-ausländer vor die kamera wollen die
allerwenigsten die wirbel stück weil sie
sozusagen wie ein rettungsanker ist
sollte und sie birgt einen vulkan in der
gesellschaft wie solvent ihren
druckkessel dass die leute endlich hoch
geben
viermal die woche gibt es umsonst eine
warme mahlzeit wilfried winzer selbst
rentner bereitet jägerschnitzel mit
nudeln vor ehrenamtlich alles finanziert
aus spenden
an diesem tag wird für 40 hungrig auf
vier herdplatten gekocht selbst gekocht
weil der lieferpreis für das lunchpaket
von 3 eur auf 4 eur 50 stieg zu teuer
hier wird mit jedem cent gerechnet
alltag für den armuts beauftragten von
neukölln
wer hierher kommt der bekommt auch wir
fragen nicht wo er herkommt das einzige
ist die sprachbarriere die wir dann
haben der voi überlegen haben wir jemand
der jetzt diese sprache spricht die
menschen in der tee und wärmestube
müssen in der regel von 300 euro im
monat leben dessen strom gas und miete
alles wird teurer die erste
einmalzahlung aus dem entlastungspaket
einst ist längst verbraucht ein leben am
limit was kann man da noch sparen
sparen
ja sieht einfach zu dass man mit den
lebensmittel besser länger klar kommt
ihm teilt mehr eintöpfe kocht und auf
fleisch und einige sachen die ihm teils
sehr teuer geworden sind halt verzichtet
bei mir persönlich zum beispiel kapanen
frühstücksei auf den tisch weil ich mir
früher jeden tag gekocht habe habe ja
von meiner grundsicherung noch den
sprung zahlen können und jetzt korrekt
vier eier und es drei tage halten haltet
durch bald zum beispiel dreimal bayer
kommt armut eine stimme geben das ist
der job von thomas diva hall dem
61-jährigen kirchenmann fällt es immer
schwerer ängste zu zerstreuen
für rentner und grundsicherungsbeziehern
fordert er schnelle hilfe meine
dringende bitte an die bundesregierung
das habe ich schon hundertmal formuliert
bevor dieser sozial tsunami auf uns
zurollt
grundnahrungsmittel mit der
mehrwertsteuer weg wir machen eine ganz
klaren schnitt sagen ich gebe jetzt
meine zahl vor 1000 kw für strom 1000 kw
für heizung für jede einzelperson und
zwar für den preis vor der korona
pandemie auswege aus der krise die gibt
es für den armuts beauftragten in
neukölln steht hier die neue tee und
wärmestube
+16 übernachtungs zimmer für die ärmsten
der armen es klingt bescheiden aber für
die war wohl ein wichtiges zeichen
und jetzt macht nochmal dieselbe weiter
mit anderen themen im rhein main gebiet
haben tausende fahrradfahrer für eine
hessische verkehrswende demonstriert
über zwei gesperrte autobahnen radelten
sie von frankfurt nach wiesbaden wo sie
verkehrsminister al wazir mehr als
70.000 unterschriften für ein
volksbegehren übergaben ihre forderungen
bis 2030 soll der verkehr in hessen
klimaneutral werden unter anderem durch
den ausbau der radwege und des
öffentlichen nahverkehrs
mit den beiden sonntagsspielen ist bei
der fußball bundesliga der vierte
spieltag zu ende gegangen werder bremen
verlor zu hause gegen eintracht
frankfurt mit 3 24 die partie köln gegen
stuttgart endete torlos 0 0
formel 1 weltmeister max verstappen hat
den großen preis von belgien gewonnen
und damit seine wm führung weiter
ausgebaut von startplatz 14 legte er
eine imposante aufholjagd hin und fuhr
ins bad zum neunten saisonsieg
zweiter wurde sein red bull kollege
sergio perez gefolgt von ferrari pilot
carlos sainz
der mensch soll wieder zum mond die nasa
startet dafür eine neue mission namens
artemis passend benannt nach der antiken
mondgöttin nach über 50 jahren sollen
wieder astronauten auf dem mond landen
aber nicht nur für eine kleine
stippvisite sondern es soll dort eine
art basis camp errichtet werden so in
etwa könnte das dann aussehen
bis es soweit ist wird erst mal eine
neue raumstation gebaut die als
beobachtungsposten und hightech labor um
den mode kreist auch sie trägt einen
symbolischen namen gateway ein tor in
die tiefen des alls
ähnlich wie die iss wird sie aus modulen
verschiedener raumfahrtagenturen
zusammengesetzt eine internationale
kooperation
diesmal allerdings ohne die russen
gateway ist übrigens im vergleich zur
alten internationalen raumstation
deutlich kleiner zu beginn haben da nur
maximal vier personen platz
möglich werden soll die mondmissionen
mit hilfe einer neuen schwerlast rakete
für morgen ist ein testflug angesetzt
susanne freitag ist für uns am cape
canaveral
amerika kehrt zurück steht auf den
artemis t shirts sie haben 10.000
nachdrucken lassen modisches must-have
zum historischen raketen stadt seit mehr
als 30 jahren verkaufen sie space t
shirts ihr so viel umsatz hatten sie
noch nie
das ist ein echter start für das volk
artemis wir kehren zum mond zurück zum
ersten mal seit den apollo missionen die
menschen haben so lange darauf gewartet
vor der tür steht ab jetzt das modell
der super rakete sls ein paar kilometer
weiter das original startrampe 39b am
kennedy space center in cape können
die stadt ist voll mit astro prominenz
der esa generaldirektor fiebert einem
historischen moment entgegen europa ist
dieses mal mit dabei auf dem weg zum
mond
europa war bisher zuschauer bei den mond
missionen in den 60er und anfang der
70er jahre und dieses mal ist europa
dabei das heißt amerika kann nicht ohne
die usa und europa zurück zum mond
fliegen die logos von nasa und esa
gemeinsam auf der raumkapsel die bald
wieder menschen zum mond bringen soll
damit sie dort oben atmen können
treibstoff und wasser haben wurde das
esm das europäische service modul gebaut
zehn länder haben zusammengearbeitet
deutschland hat den größten anteil
geliefert es ist ein ganz besonderer
moment gerade für deutschland denn nach
50 jahren geht es wieder zum mond und
diesmal mit unserer technologie 50
prozent des europäischen service moduls
das bei der rakete ganz wichtig ist
werden von deutschland bezahlt und komme
aus bremen also deutsche hochtechnologie
die zum mond fliegt das ist was ganz
besonderes
1 1 ist ein unbemannter testflug das
raumschiff orion wird zweieinhalb mal
den mond umrunden und daten erheben erst
bei der nächsten missionen werden
astronauten an bord sein die botschaft
eine andere als vor 50 jahren damals war
es ein wettrennen ost gegen west diesmal
ist es ein zurückkehren zum mond
zurückkehren um zu bleiben
dazu wollen sie das luna gateway bauen
einer raumstation die den astronauten
als basislager dient um den mond zu
erforschen später könnte sie
zwischenstopp seien auf dem weg zum mars
die vorstellung dass einer von uns einer
von uns menschen einmal auf dem mars
sein wird dort ja aus dem raumschiff
aussteigen wird und erfahren wird wie
der mars sich anfühlt es ist eine
großartige vorstellung
erstmal ist jetzt countdown auf dem weg
zum mut artemis 1 startet in eine neue
ära der reifen
online finden sie dazu auch noch eine
umfängliche 3d grafik in unserer zdf
heute app oder auf der webseite können
sie sich selbst auf den weg ins all
machen und sich zum mond klicken treppen
und zoomen und interaktiv die neue
raumstation erkunden und so noch mehr
erfahren über die mondmissionen artemis
und ihr großes fernziel den menschen auf
den mars zu bringen
und hier bei uns gibt es jetzt noch den
ausblick darauf was uns nächste woche
erwartet zumindest an vorhersehbaren an
der kaiser hat einige wichtige termine
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
zum wochenstart wird bundeskanzler
scholz in prag mit dem tschechischen
ministerpräsidenten vieler
zusammentreffen an der karlsuniversität
wird scholz eine rede zur lage in europa
halten
das bundeskabinett wird dienstag und
mittwoch zu einer klausur ab schloss
meseberg zusammen kommen wichtige themen
die energiekrise und mögliche entlastung
da am mittwoch 9 euro ticket und tank
rabatt auslaufen werden und nord stream
1 für drei tage abgeschaltet wird sind
die erwartungen an die
abschlusspressekonferenz hoch
am donnerstag will die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde über die zulassung
der omicron booster von bei und tech und
moderner entscheiden biotec kündigte an
seinen impfstoff innerhalb weniger tage
ausliefern zu können
am 83 jahrestag des deutschen überfalls
auf polen und damit auch am donnerstag
soll in warschau ein gutachten zu den
erlittenen schäden im zweiten weltkrieg
vorgestellt werden die polnische pis
regierung thematisiert immer wieder
reparation ansprüche an deutschland die
bundesregierung sieht dafür keine
rechtliche grundlage
wir komplettieren den ausblick mit dem
wetter aussichten die neue woche startet
im norden teils dicht bewölkt mit
vereinzelten regen nach süden hin wird
die mischung aus sonne und wolken
freundlicher 19 bis 29 grad in den
folgenden tagen gibt es an der ostsee
einzelne schauer im süden gewitter meist
bleibt es aber freundlich und trocken
bei 18 bis 28 grad
das war es im heute journal an diesem
sonntagabend und weiter geht es gleich
mit kommissar beck ja und wer lange
aufbleiben gibt es dann nochmal
nachrichten gegen fünf vor halb eins und
hier übernehmen morgen christian sievers
und anna zimmermann schönen abend noch
[Musik]